as we expected Kia stalma going in on
ambulance delays specifically there's
another reason he's doing that today
because at one o'clock we expect to find
out whether there will be more
Nationwide strikes from ambulance
workers in February and potentially into
March and I was with the GMB Union early
in the week as they were discussing this
with members these were closed meetings
but certainly the mood music coming out
of those meetings was there was no
resolution on pay and there could be
further strikes so this is likely to hit
the bulletins today and kit starma in
the chamber really pressing the Prime
Minister on ambulance delays and what he
did was he started off with a
hypothetical question about if you had
chest pains how long might you want to
wait for an ambulance and he then turned
that hypothetical question into a real
life story about a young woman called
Stephanie who was a cancer sufferer
lived in Plymouth the hospital was just
2.3 miles away from her home her mother
called an ambulance it didn't arrive
Stephanie lost her life and she was just
26 years old so he used her example in
the comments I have to say the chamber
went silent at that moment and then
after or during prime minister's
questions labor then put out a press
release as you were talking about saying
37
000 patients with conditions like heart
attacks and strokes have waited more
than three and a half hours for an
ambulance in December so labor really
pressing in on this as for the Prime
Minister he did as we suspected he would
he said I am trying to make sure there
are minimum service levels when that a
strikes new labor are not backing me and
you're not doing that because he would
argue the Prime Minister you're in the
pocket of the Union so he brought back
in in to point this idea about minimum
service levels and kirstama retorted by
saying you there aren't minimum service
levels on normal days for the NHS so
another uncomfortable prime minister's
questions there uh for Rishi sooner
because these battles go on over strikes
and as I said before prime minister's
questions from a government point of
view
um they are content in the the
contingency plans that the cabinet
office put in place uh for for military
staff to man ambulances to try and keep
service levels they are they are pleased
in a way with their contingency plans
that they did work
um and their hope is I guess
um that they can keep those contingency
plans go in but the problem they have is
the public do not blame Poland suggests
public sector workers for the strikes
they blame the government for not
resolving them and there is sympathy for
public sector workers that work really
hard and they'll suffering because of
these crazy levels of inflation that is
really eaten into people's wages and
cost of living so another round of
strikes do still negotiations ongoing
but I would argue that the pressure on
the government to try and resolve this
is ratcheting up as the strikes look to
go not to January but into February and
March and it's going to be another set
of bad headlines for the government
today when as I suspect at one o'clock
ambulance workers announce more strikes